let's move on to Jay Leno who at this
point we just may need to Bubble Wrap
after he dropped this shocking admission
[Music]
after nearly losing his life in a freak
car explosion Jay reveals he suffered
yet another major accident when he fell
off of one of his vintage 1940 Indian
Motorcycles causing quote a broken
collarbone two broken ribs and two
cracked kneecaps take a licking keep on
ticking that was Jay earlier today
driving to his garage without any
noticeable injuries he told the Las
Vegas Review Journal the accident
occurred January 17th during a test
drive he noticed the scent of leaking
gas and pulled into a parking lot when
quote some guy had a wire strung across
the parking lot but with no flag hanging
from it I didn't see it until it was too
late it just clotheslined me and boom
knocked me off the bike it's pretty easy
to start
and they're incredibly smooth the 72
year old late night Legend says he
didn't go public about the accident
until now because of the media frenzy
surrounding his hospitalization for
third-degree Burns last November Jay
says his recovery is going well and he
can still perform this week again the
comic practiced what could be a new bit
with the paparazzi I was riding my
motorcycle up in Lake Tahoe I came
around the corner and crashed into
Jeremy Runner snow plow
Jay also took another hit in stride
CNBC announced they are canceling his
Prime Time series Jay Leno's Garage
thanks for watching bye-bye the decision
nj's three decades-long relationship
with MBC that's all right we'll we'll go
somewhere else with it